hi i'm genevieve aaron o'brien some of
my friends call me erin o'brien and
other friends call me geo and today i'm
making geo's post pop two of my
signature flavors i'm gonna make the
curio and unicorn union i am a
conceptual performance artist which
means i have advanced degrees in make
believe which also means i make
performances
out of whatever i like and in this case
i made popcorn um each of these popcorns
is inspired by friends and post-colonial
ideas so to me queer cuisine is in the
context of queer the verb to trouble to
make different to subvert the dominant
paradigm if we think about popcorn as
one of the oldest snacks dating back
three to four thousand years how can we
make that different how can we flip the
script on popcorn how can we take what
we think of as a common snack that
everybody recognizes and try savory
flavors and unexpected pairings curio uh
is meant to sound like curio so the idea
is it's uh where indian curry actually
dominates english cheddar for a little
reverse colonization everyone's familiar
with cheese popcorn and who doesn't love
cheese popcorn but if we think about
postcoloniality and where the colonial
empire has been subverted then we
actually have a place where curry can be
the dominant flavor and it actually
pairs really well with english cheddar
it's very hard to find chinese chives
dehydrated in the market in fact if you
find them i'd be really impressed but
you can make your own dried herbs not to
worry just take fresh chinese chives and
go ahead and leave the door open on the
lowest temperature about 200 for about
30 minutes and then you can close the
door and it'll take about an hour to two
hours for those chives to crisp up
unicorn union is actually inspired by my
friend ilokin my buddy diem they wanted
to surprise their boo with a little
present for their birthday and they
actually commissioned this popcorn and
so i wanted to do something that
represented her personality so of course
it has a little bit of nutritional yeast
because you know what's a queer without
a little nutrition and it has a little
bit of lemongrass
and lavender because of course we all
need to relax a little bit and a little
pink peppercorn because well it just
looks like glitter and we can all use a
little extra queer glitter in our life
you know as a conceptual performance
artist i like to talk about big ideas
but i do that through food i use food as
my medium i can't actually paint and you
don't want me to paint i can't draw but
i can express concepts and ideas through
the food and i think food touches us in
a way that it evokes something right you
have to take a risk in order to
experience it it's very different than
standing in in front of a framed
two-dimensional artwork and so for me
being able to use food as a way to
explore these ideas of identity and home
and even queerness is a really powerful
medium to share a story oh yes
you